muito obrigado
eu vou tentar convencer a é sucinto é
que o que vou contar e um pouco um ovo
meu antecessor o antónio pedro também
tentar falar que queria sobre aquilo que
me trouxe até aqui
em termos curso de vida é uma razão
muito simples é a primeira questão é
agradecer e venda de alex viseu
vamos ter combinado afirmando assim
também um museu uma casa da cultura quer
todos nós
em seu lugar porque enfim com sono
ativamente dos conhecidos na realidade a
vizinha se apresentar será o fim com tom
é dizer quem sou e offline e portanto
tentar atualizar meu tempo é dos 15
minutos incluindo última dizem quem
soube como eu cheguei aqui não chegou à
cidade de cinco minutos para tentar
dizer que o que eu acho que seria
interessante
exemplo não sei só os barcos um exemplo
mais um de vida podem ajudar a
construção de alguns novos
empreendimentos ltda cada um eo último
com um pequeno vídeo promocional próprio
museu em um cenário que nós estamos
recorrendo para me apresentar em um
movimento chamado ganhar aqui falar um
pouco da minha vida que é isso que eu
vou tentar fazer sem ser neste momento o
soldo e com os avanços que quando fui
convidado para fazer esta intervenção
não me sentia muito bem
não não gosto muito de falar de mim mas
vou tentar fazer um crime porque acho
que eu venho da minha parte dar a
conhecer pela quem um pouco menos vai
ter este esta preocupação nos dizer
alguma coisa sobre o sol eu faço
ele entrou captação do distrito viseu
natural diesel tom que no concelho do
norte de s
se é precisamente a 23 de outubro 57 58
anos ea mulher com saúde ouvidos em
outubro a dizerem que o tinha sido em
2002 já há muito tempo eu rio também
porque achei piada facto a noção do
tempo é muito relativa e tem tudo a ver
como enfim com ele lá dentro deus assim
o relatório pedro saiu mais velho
considerar com cinco anos pelo sabe que
é importante é a minha segunda terra
gosto muitos amigos da minha vida
digamos assim da minha ausência e foi
computada com essas vivências e consigo
e que é importante e vivi e estou em
moçambique até 1974 na altura tinha
assim alguma atender a separar as artes
dramáticas para a expansão da marca por
teatro é e eu saí como muitos muitos
portugueses que estavam nas colônias
para sair portugal precisamente depois
do 25 de abril de 1974 tinha 17 anos
acho que essa idéia não é nada
extraordinário e é exatamente por nós e
muitos aqui presentes são jovens contas
assembléia é exata em que crê ter um
tenho duas balas tanques cheios de
sonhos estamos perfeitamente preparados
digamos assim para a vida
isso é verdade mas tem que ser
normatizado com as outras componentes e
os perguntas que nós devemos fazer
eu também estava com essa intenção
primeiro fui estudar ao adversário
de uma maneira que achou que era a mais
adequada em função das circunstâncias
saiu precisamente na escola do
magistério primário do planeta primário
é uma actividade profissional que
desenvolve ao longo de alguns anos e que
me orgulha é imenso é talvez uma delas
uma das áreas profissionais que eu não
desenvolvi durante muito tempo mas que
marcaram profundamente em termos meu
percurso da minha vida profissional
depois nessa altura cumprir o primário
um museu do flamengo que é um seu
magnífico convido todos a visitar que é
fato extraordinário flamengo se estava a
criar o seu serviço educativo do museu
fui convidado por lei o serviço criação
fechamento do serviço educativo ea
partir daí não mais havendo aí a minha
vida obrigada exatamente aos museus com
sei que não usem o banheiro consegue
tratar do zeus museologia e património e
da cultura dentro daquilo que era enfim
o meu conhecimento e as minhas
capacidades
entrei de cabeça e lá fui para a vida
dos céus não é importante também tive
alguns percursos é no magistério
primário saída do aluno transformem o
soro
fui dar aula de step primário trabalhei
com o seu nas áreas de serviço educativo
fazendo essas relações institucionais
entre o museu
licenciei-me em coimbra em história
exatamente para dar capacidade e corpo
conquista da propagação é daí a
competência e também na política foi
vereador fui presidente da câmara do
negro e foi membro da assembleia
municipal portanto tive mais ou menos
este percurso antiga uma pós-graduação
fiz mestrado em museologia e depois fui
trabalhar
é é em várias atividades ao nível do
zoológico é minha base o trabalho foi no
seu nome e no civil 10 do número 35 anos
é ao serviço nesta casa de cultura é e
os últimos 20 como diretora desta casa
magnífica instalada no pólo sempre quem
for ao norte do distrito e visitará a
zona também com jogos o flamengo tem
obras aos hoteleiros notáveis e que são
elementos identitários da nossa cultura
o nosso património fala apenas facto o
uso fluir verificar é e posso dizer que
o meu trabalho finalmente possa conduzir
a uma tão que é muito importante a
palavra serviço eu sou um servidor da
causa pública
não fiz outra coisa na minha vida tem
esse momento que não seja exatamente o
de servir servir
enfim não não consigo
infelizmente é para a instabilidade no
museu também foi um dos responsáveis por
crimes são 12
membro do conselho de administração
daquela instituição
temos fundacionais e os municipais eo
lucro
deus em cristo
o quilo
da minha vida para percebermos todos o
que é que eu estou aqui a fazer
estamos aqui a fazer exatamente uma
espécie de uma sugestão de um convite
para vivermos o nosso museu o museu
nacional grão vasco que recebeu
exatamente esse título no ano passado no
dia internacional dos museus foi dia 18
de maio
eu não era o seu
o funda e
um patrimônio em pinha e tem um
patrimônio no terreno em cima um
patrimônio de primeira linha na firma
saúde da identidade cultural e artística
em termos nacionais sobretudo com as
obras desse magnífico pintor no
regimento português trabalhou e deixou
uma pulsão magnífica em viseu ao vasco
pior faixa informante eram baixa é o
título de cidadão quase como se fosse um
mal que eu era foi reconhecido
imediatamente como o grande risco e
sendo o grande do vasco é assim
conseguiu a titularidade de se ter um
calvário eo museu que foi criada em 1917
museu da república teve exatamente esta
perspectiva de nunca ter alcançado o
título museu nacional ao contrário do
que acontecia com muitos outros 200
souto situados nas grandes cidades
lisboa quer capital e do povo esporte
como se nossas leis e coimbra com o
museu nacional machado castro todos os
outros não tinham essa titularidade nos
museus enfim considerados
independentemente da valia do seu
património artístico seu acervo eram
considerados museus hoje vamos ser pura
e simplesmente mas nós conseguimos
através do trabalho enfim de alguma
insistência junto dos decisores
políticos
este título ano passado precisamente a
preparar é que vai ser todo o ano de
2016 que são enfim é que é o ano do
nosso centenário
nós não vamos só este já na área do
museu e comemorar o centenário do museu
no dia da fundação no dia 16 março foi o
dia da publicação em diário do governo
exatamente dessa dessa dessa
constituição dessa fundação do museu mas
vamos desenvolvendo um conjunto de
atividades ao longo do ano de janeiro a
dezembro de 2016 para precisa de dar
maior amplitude e abrangência é todas as
comemorações relacionadas e associadas é
este magnífico museu crise eu tem que
vencer tem acarinhado e viseu vai
continuar sobrevento a caminhar na sua
melhora e expressão e na sua mais
a informação é que nós queremos fazer
que é uma infelicidade uma por um lado
mais amplitude de projetos em eventos de
realizações que permitam exatamente um
museu é possa ser enfim cada vez mais
conhecido e reconhecido como instituição
de cultura em controlava no panorama
nacional e até mesmo internacional
bom é mas eu gostaria só para achar um
pouco e que o consideram ser importante
pois o meu percurso de vida um pouco
fazer também a ideia daquilo que eu acho
que é importante que possamos fazer a
voz precisamente para enfim falar vamos
fazê-los pedindo que é dizer vos da
minha da minha vida foi sempre conduzido
por algumas normas
eu acho que devemos utilizar sempre
- tentei fazê lo de dizer sempre mais
sim do canal tentar sempre corresponder
positivamente de ajuda de apoio com o
processo muito grande para um chá muitos
dos meus ambições aqui o feriram a
participação de partilha é a minha
resposta do tendencialmente era sempre
assim vamos brigar as condições para que
o facto isto aconteça
devo dizer que meu partido todo esse
trabalho proferida num trabalho
desenvolvido por ronaldinho sempre em
mim é minha remuneração inicial que era
funcionário público e tudo o mais era
num trabalho que eu dava em termos de
ajuda às outras organizações 30
instituições dentro daquilo que era meu
sim é importante dizer sim mais vezes
tem até do que não sobre as coisas
importantes sim a igualdade assim a
fraternidade
assim a expectativa de vida à liberdade
e ao direito à diferença
cimento das culturas que o conhecimento
das outras culturas faz a aproximação e
não cria medos não criam sites não cria
é depois em fios todos os motivos que
levam é normalmente a guerra ea e ame ea
segregação sim a aproximação dos povos
na descoberta dos outros ao saber a
cultura a arte é e depois interpessoais
que andou por cada vez que é solicitado
por aí sim vamos fazer sim planos
contribuir sim estou aqui eu junto conta
comigo
vamos fazer um show com zezé que não
iríamos de vez em quando a crise não não
também é importante na sua perspectiva
correta
também devemos dizer não mas não é aos o
uso do poder ou não à discriminação à
subserviência à corrupção a falta de
respeito ao turismo às drogas a miséria
ea fome que é o fiel caso é causa de
tudo aquilo que neste momento constrói
as grandes os grandes maus que enfrenta
a humanidade de um ponto de vista como é
que estes faz o faça através da vida
normal judeus perguntar então mas isto
tem a ver alguma coisa com nossa própria
humanidade tem tudo a ver com esse fluxo
formos assim nas pequenas coisas que
fazemos no dia a dia na escola os amigos
em casa é através de tudo aquilo que nós
vamos desenvolver nós estamos a
construir sombreamento uma sociedade
melhor porque é nas pequenas coisas da
nossa vida que nós podemos construir
é essa vida em sociedade melhor portanto
eu é que o que quero dizer é que o da
mesma forma com todos os outros de
disseram desde já é não vale a pena
estarmos a esperar sentados que as
coisas aconteçam
tudo pode acontecer de facto mas tem que
ser nós também é provocar o
acontecimento é tentar encontrar as
melhores soluções e fazer tudo o que
estiver ao nosso alcance para que estas
nestas condições não sejam proveitosas
para toda a nossa vida portanto quero é
que há alguma alguma coisa do tipo disso
é conhecido enfim importante mecânica no
sentido de sabermos em que percebemos
não só sabia palma e aquilo que é
importante é e que isso tem essa vida
enfim em termos pessoais e profissionais
18 a vossa atenção e também ia dizendo
que nada de estranho é possível se não
tivesse de facto uma família é é
suportar e fazer tudo isto eo
agradecimento à minha mulher que se
encontra a presença ea todos vós também
e ao meu filho são aquelas que são os
motivos em algum momento também não
temos fazem os motivos da nossa
verdadeira flu ensina que a felicidade
está nas pessoas e não está nas coisas
comigo agora ver o vídeo do museu
nacional do vasco estão todos convidados
a participar em todos os eventos que nós
vamos desenvolver ao longo de 2016
bem haja por vossa atenção